[Musik]
die dreiteilige serie spezial über das
leben wieder fangs leben doch im
geburtshaus ambra sind schon 600 53 auto
zweite sohn vor der orgaphone muss das
ist die janosch und so eine geburt der
städte aus leider vor älteren immer
öfter mal ist es anders als dass man
sich das vorstellt oder finde ich so aus
dass man sich der grünen steht oder von
muss wohl doch nicht gelang sie sind
eine dreißigsten märz 2007 2 und die a
mannschaft weil die wähler im moment
einzig merkt deutschland besonders er
selber gar nicht merkt kommt diese obama
will nach der geburt gesagt hat das war
schon ganz änderungen hat trisomie 21
und erstellen waren der ganzen
schwangerschaft
nein nein es ist unwissenheit sie sich
das nicht wissen was das heißt sie muss
man viel gedanken wo es in you feel bild
trotzdem
aber grundsatz franziska ich habe extra
[Musik]
wird alltag vor der familie von web.de
möglich an kz3 leuten begleitet
davon hatten am ersten geburtstag im
land das jansch heute seinen ersten
geburtstag feiern kann ist nicht
selbstverständlich
kurz nach seiner geburt nämlich brachte
ihm ein darmverschluss und die
darauffolgende operation an den rand von
leben und tod
eine häufige komplikation beim down
syndrom einen monat musste er auf der
intensivstation des kinderspitals beider
basel verbringen bevor er nach hause so
eltern und blut durfte
[Musik]
olga von moos war 30 jahre alt als
janosch erwartete im besten alter
gewissermaßen knapp zwei jahre zuvor
hatte sie schon einen jungen geboren
tor in keinerlei anlass also sich
während der schwangerschaft irgendwelche
sorgen zu machen als die hebamme dann
kurz nach janus geburt den verdacht
äußerte der kleine habe das down-syndrom
waren die jungen eltern erstmal
verunsichert
was wenn das kind behindert ist bei der
orga noch jemand mich hat man sich
bisher ernsthaft mit dieser frage
auseinandergesetzt was heißt das
eigentlich
das heiße dass er schwarze dass er
gesundheitlich hinter das gesundheitlich
wird block leben oder das heißt das
alles und dennoch merkt mit helma
geredet und geredet und nein das heißt
nicht dass er muss leader denis kreuth
umso größer
spanisch drauf was was uns das leben
bringt eines von 700 babys weltweit hat
das down-syndrom trisomie 21 genannt
dabei handelt es sich um eine
veränderung des erbguts in jeder
einzelnen zelle ist das chromosom 21
nicht doppelt sondern dreifach vorhanden
[Musik]
so fordern sowie logistik und dann doch
das becken hier plötzlich viel für jeden
in der chance
[Musik]
[Applaus]
orgaphone muss ist steinbildhauerin
heute besucht sie den steinbruch in
lasberg theora kalk für die arbeit im
atelier
zunächst studierte die baselbieterin
kunst aber das war mir zu wenig konkret
deshalb machte sie die vierjährige
bildhauer lehre und stieg dann ins
geschäft ihres vaters ein
das brachte auch einen weiteren großen
vorteil
mit den großeltern in der unmittelbaren
nachbarschaft kann die arbeit und
familie optimal verbinden das für sie
mal einen gedanken sie dass sie wieder
auf höhere kurse hinein schon
miteinander gesprochen dass wenn sie
überhaupt mann sowie tragen dass das
klar ist dass beide waffen in privater
hand ist einlösbar
der beruf geht es nach ich habe mich
gezwungen wird
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
olga von moos hat keine vorgeburtlichen
untersuchungen gemacht obwohl seit
einigen jahren ein einfacher bluttest
auf dem markt ist der promi sehr
zuverlässig erkennen kann
seit 2005 10 bezahlt von der
krankenkasse
laut studien entscheiden sich über 90
prozent der paare bei trisomie vertrag
für eine abtreibung das wäre für olga
und ihren mann nie in frage gekommen
man solle versuchen die steine weg zu
räumen die einem das schicksal in den
weg lege findet olga und sie als
bildhauerin habe da noch ganz andere
werkzeuge zur verfügung was machen so
schön ist wenn sie einen tag vorgesehen
und das ist wie immer dass sie das muss
auch in der lehre man vielleicht der
zahlung mit dem jahren schäfer gerade
extrem nomi letztes jahr hätte ich so
wahnsinnig viele frauen drücken
eric stevens nicht so weit wie möglich
hier gegangen aber wenn sie ja nicht
gestoppt werden
aldi und die schwierige sache wenn du
bist gut
das jahr seit januar geburt war
schwierig und sorgenvoll und hat die
junge familie auf eine harte probe
gestellt
an ihre liebe aber hat und gar nie
gezweifelt dass man da wird der gehalt
ich merke er steht dass sie als wichtige
politische stellenwert hat das metall
verständlich dass man das so
[Musik]
die kinderbetreuung teilen sich olga und
mich auf dass sie kinder wollten war
ihnen bald einmal klar und den
grundlegenden erziehungsfragen sind sie
sich einig zum beispiel auch darin dass
sie der freien entwicklung ihrer kinder
viel raum geben wollen sie klavier die
exakt die speziell welle fördern und das
gen die aktion möglichst bald losgehen
aber nach wenig überhaupt normal wachsen
sondern wieviel ohne förderung geht es
aber nicht daniela oder markt eine
logopädin kommt auf hausbesuch ganz ganz
nah
[Musik]
sie beobachtet wie janosch ist perfekt
denen ich bin es geht so eine zunge stoß
womöglich verhindern und das klingt wenn
man druck auf zum im richtigen moment
macht und deutschland das richtige
flugzeug nach karlstadt ii verbindet die
körperspannung ist das sehr anstrengend
und da wird er hat schnell gelernt
jeder löffel einkauf aber aufgeben ist
keine option
neben das hat ja nun seit seiner geburt
bewiesen
die nachfrage habe ich einfach völlig
schlaf und das wichtig dass er eine
andere therapie wo alle in die gleiche
richtung schaffte das sie unterstützt
sind und eine sehr engagierte machen
womit kaum setzen und den editors und
durchsuchbar zu machen will das angebot
sogar zwölf läufe und den runter und
dann muss man nur verhalten die hufe
rolle und logisch
wichtig ist dass die batterie mit bis
mindestens wir sonst tun hätten
die kamera täter die kernthemen impuls
obere führt das klipp darüber stimmt
dass das was da hat er sein dass das
dann kommt die förderung von menschen
mit trisomie hat große fortschritte
gemacht auch medizinisch sind die
prognosen heute viel besser als früher
die lebenserwartung ist in den letzten
jahrzehnten von 20 auf 60 jahre
angestiegen
sozial gebiete kommen besser integrierte
in schulischer sind ich auch hin und
unterstütze diese mehr sprachen und sind
sehr lang in regelschulen und henkel
titel reicher das riesige unterschied
also dass ich große faktor und man kann
nicht alle down-syndrom hin also
präsidentin des ok
[Musik]
janosch ist sehr herzlich willkommen
das steht außer zweifel seine eltern
haben sich auf ein tempo eingestellt
andere kinder in seinem alter können
sitzen und krabbeln manche schon gehen
es ist alles so schön werden wie der app
ist freut größte falsch aus die netze
irgendwie weiß man das ist normal
es ist nicht einfach normal ist das
völlig wurst auf die zeit
[Musik]
inzwischen ist schon wieder alles gut
aus sieht man wie heiß sie sehen das
familienerbe mit dem janus dokumentiert
was ich sehr gerne sehr viel
also es ist einfacher geworden weil er
mich also fortbewegen
jetzt hat romy schneider machte er
steffi sich also ein staat aus der
gegend urheber und fortbewegen gegen der
kunde einfach mit ja
[Gelächter]
und es ist wunderbar dass nach dem
schwierigen start in das ich habe mich
sehr widrigkeiten wo mich aber wundert
das niveau ist viele die erste chance
der moment war hart und ich sage ganz
offen kurz muss ich sagen dass
verschiedene stars unter den tisch dass
der kurs und der augen und ob er jetzt
eigentlich beraten etwas nur ganz mal
von ganz kurzer viertelstunde bleibt
wieso der ganz einfach ist zwischen ems
und mein name ist es rund und beliebt
ist gedanklich noch vordergrund steht
ist das wichtigste
ist das gesund sie dass er immer wieder
therapie hat also immer wieder
untersuchen
in spittal muss das gehört eigentlich
software steht fix bleiben so ein
familienleben dazu und hände ein ich
deine untersuchungen begleiten lassen
sich am besten so erstmal wird gern erst
kurzen wir sprechen ja wie ist das so
wie schläft er der erste nachwuchs ok
sehr bild nimmt es so ein bisschen zu
klappern jetzt auch einen blauen an
sondern bis eine variante reagierte
schon auf seinen namen das gefühl
reagiert auf den namen sie rufen
android ist eben die benötigten aber das
ist okay so gemacht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
er tut jetzt eher internet eine hand an
tieren arbeiten in dem sinn ist es auch
bis wasser überwiegend zu hause
beobachtet so ist die manuelle ja immer
einseitig stützen und mittel andere hand
in hand nachhaltig greifen
okay aber nicht trisomie 21 betroffenen
kinder normal entwickelten kindern ist
es so dass die händigkeit sich erst
danach deutlich nach dem zweiten
geburtstag ausbildet also umgekehrt wir
haben es gar nicht gern wenn es zu früh
eigentlich eine händigkeit auf das
schöne körperspannung das geld
[Musik]
ich wäre froh wenn sie ihn einmal ganz
kurz die strumpfhose abziehen könnte das
stumpfe aber ich finde es schön
muskeltonus das muss man sagen also
erhält mit den schlaf sagt das haben wir
oft sehr gut jetzt machen wir da auch
einmal auf seinen rücken anschauen ob er
gerade ist wenn er sitzt schön rücken
geht nicht in rundrücken noch rüber was
aber bei den kindern muss man auch immer
ein bisschen aufpassen ist dass sie ab
und zu so einer wirbelsäulenverkrümmung
bekommen können auf die seite hin aber
erst jetzt schön stabilisiert eigentlich
ganz gut da ist es wichtig ist da jetzt
schon ein bisschen was vom tisch mit
oder das gar nicht also hauptsächlich
bei interessierten was obama aber nicht
das ist bis zum gefahren
71 2 und letzte noch mal auch noch etwas
erfreuliches
doch das am herzen ja soweit zwar ein
kleiner herzfehler da ist aber sonst
eigentlich keine großen probleme hat in
einem jahr
ich glaube das nächste ist sicher dass
noch darauf fokussieren sollte das jetzt
sicher und stabil sitzen kann weil dann
eröffnet sich für ihn auch eine ganz
andere welt in dem sehen dann kann man
ganz anders auch am aktiv leben teil
ich glaub das ist oder nächste punkt
dass das krabbeln und es sitzen lernen
und das ist sicherlich eine aufgabe von
der physiotherapie die sie dabei
begleiten kann das ist deswegen finde
ich das cool dass er das einmal in der
woche macht man sollte eben auch darauf
achten dass die kinder nicht
über therapien werden also auch schon
ein bisschen schützen davor zu sagen
eigentlich nicht mehr als zwei
therapieformen für die kinder dann weil
vom mehr können wir noch nicht
profitieren hingegen sehen und sie
sollen sie auch aus essen natürlich ein
antrieb auch noch ein bisschen natürlich
weiterentwickeln können und nicht nur
von therapien zur therapie laufen
viel ist vorbei wir sie als familie
leben aber von janosch entwickelt
einfach nicht bewusst sieht aber noch
mal schnell zu dem moment wo auf der
welt sie haben sich bewusst gegen so
eine pränatale und besucher entschieden
und gesagt da mache ich nicht warum
willy scilla wenn ich an die
schwangerschaft so untersucht gemacht
hat also es muss dir flogen wenn es
heißt sie durchmachen
mit dem be und wie gut es den vito
zahnlos wie trio machen nachdem und wenn
ich dein größter mannschaft so dass es
dann den raum hat hat mir wahnsinnig
unsicher also dr
die nämlich eine mannschaft die es
einfach nicht gefühllos wilden hat hat
sie gar für immer die gut gemachte
bilder wo vielleicht bewahrheitet sind
vielleicht nicht probier straps
vorstellungen ist ja also völlig
unnötige eigentlich hat man denn hektik
in die schwangerschaft gebracht und so
da und sie im nachhinein 1
das ist möglich dass ein star zu sein
sie finde
[Musik]
ihr lebensentwurf hat sich für diese
familie als richtig erwiesen
generationenübergreifend arbeiten
räumliche nähe die die integration von
familie in den berufsalltag zulässt und
unbeschwert dank nichtwissens olga und
michi haben sich bewusst gegen pränatale
diagnostik entschieden
nicht zuletzt auch deshalb weil sie
nicht durch eine diagnose verunsichert
werden wollten
und wenn vorgeburtliche untersuchungen
schlechter scheideweg und da müssen alle
drei war mir am tisch sitzen kommen dann
noch mal geräten häufig hebammen und
trauerbegleiterin und dann als barbies
sind lehrer und der sieg ist ihr war die
em im letzten jahr mit dem zweiten kind
schwanger und dann plötzlich bei
vorgeburtlichen das stimmt also einer
der schlimmsten tage wartezeit nicht
dass ich meine erschoss findet und ich
ja marketing nicht so ist das ist ganz
schlimm ich sehe eigentlich meint der
biz weg ist als das ist im moment
genießt das sind sichere form von
rechtlosigkeit max das armen und bei
viel zu wenig lang sind das muttersein
küste aber nicht im spektrum jetzt stars
eine büchse kritisch wo es ist kein
victory geistige und körperliche
beeinträchtigungen und drehen das haben
wir natürlich zurück das so ist dann
darf ich von mir dann schluss ein trotz
diagnose kaufen möchte ja blind also
moment will kann doch von der uns also
entschied doch todestag und die aber
auch gewünschtes natur österreicher also
dass wir zum schluss müssen von innen
wenn es heißt jahrzehnt rada wo es aber
nie das haus habe es muss er nicht und
entwicklung und afrika das heißt es für
koblenz bei und das geld gutes finden
wird sowieso einige stolpersteine sieht
stelle muss ich fragen zu möglichen
lebensqualität von kind und da muss
jetzt stellt man sich fragen sie sich
selber kann die verantwortung übernehmen
dass man vielleicht das kind hat wo man
seine schlimmen fall extremfall
lebenslange betreuung bucht wo nötig
einfach selber lebensfähig ist haben wir
mit dem bürger ja oder nein oder also
der gang zum einem selbsttor zum
egoistischen frau genauso hart motiv
muss ich mich lieber eigentlich bis zum
küssen gerade mit kindern oder umsorgt
die frage gott glauben
umfragen hätten das kind mit mitra
spezifisch berechtigung denn hohe
lebensqualität wo man kann jetzt zeigen
ja kamerafrau gewissen sinn oder das ist
natürlich ein sehr schwierig aber will
mario ungewissheit ich kann mir egal
oder egal was man sich vorstellt mit
findet nie eine antwort oder aber dass
das oder unserer zeit für euch bedeutet
das kind ist nicht lebensfähig
was irgendwie natürlich ist man im
moment natürlich extrem schlimm ist oder
das ist ein unglaublicher moment
aber auch und ich hatte damals den arzt
gesagt dass es aber nicht und ist eine
klare diagnose hängt ja im moment kein
entscheid fällen sind außerhalb von
[Musik]
entscheidung am schluss up geworden aber
nachdenklich
die haben wir noch nicht aber zumindest
reden das ist meine größte anschluss
steht oder versteckt oder also es ist
schon schlimm sie die ganze nacht die
ganze woche österreichers ist mit mit
sie haben keine vorstellung was ist ja
ein freundliches anders sind und man
muss ja auch wenn das funktioniert und
wie sagen wir mal kamen dann aber an ihm
funktioniert wenn man es von dieser
breiten steht dann sowieso
und darum ist ein frühes gerade - damit
macht das mit schwangerschaft aber mit
weniger budget leiter aber ja das ist
der niedrigste moment liegt das eine
normale geburt das wird gleitet die
geburt wie ihr die andere idee
ich hab das müsse da sehr viel genützt
dass das team seine geburt ist aber
natürlich unter ganz speziellen
vorzeichen mehr endlos erlebt auf mich
wie die erste geburt anstrengend sie es
ist also schlanke es ist von der durham
also gar nichts ist es endlich gang nach
essig sich anstrengen
es ist natürlich sehr sehr sexy aber
irgendwie ist auch schön sie ist ein
wichtiger schritt zum zum zum abschied
vom ring
das ist eine sehr wichtige schlag ist
ein musik geboten und für sich ja
ständig an der kaiserschnitt machen und
das ist eigentlich erst gedanken machen
denn auch und yahoo damit das kind also
sei aber wahrscheinlich am burgsee
opfers ist dein ding wie absurd aber
eben
die so noch gar nie haben sie das ist
der moment aber endlich die auf
insgesamt fast zwei tage oder oder doch
sind 26
[Musik]
gießen cw
die usk hat etliche kurz und focus
älterer herr schwierige arbeit sehr
wichtig
[Musik]
anna margaretha ley für geschichte und
viele andere geschichten ähnliche andere
erlebt als trauerbegleiterin wo sie
beratungsstelle leitet wo ältere
unterstütze genau idealsituation was ist
die erzählt vom netz - und entscheiden
das sehe ich mir unglaublich schwierig
für mich an ein mensch und ich sind
ältere überhaupt sondern den job weil
sich welt also eigentlich ist ein
unmenschlicher entscheid eigentlich die
eltern entscheiden über das ungeborene
leben als einfach wenn's ein absolutes
wunschkind ist es so wer dafür zahlt
sich somit liebe verbunden und den müsse
das kind entscheide ich eigentlich
wirklich honig und menschlich ja und ich
werde viele genau vor die vor der frage
stellt oder wahr machen wir da hilft
dann ist auch meine moment was sie dem
moment so sexy war wobei der hilft ich
war nicht so kurzen gilt und wenn das
nicht passiert dann ist eigentlich
ohnehin geht's kredite weil vermeintlich
ist dass man denkt wir machen jetzt
schnell einen abbruch und den lebensmut
wir vorher starten sexy und das ist für
mainzer zwar strategisch verteilten im
moment völlig normal ist notfalls
strategie was mehr als fachperson mich
dass dir noch die note strategie
nachhaltige schwarzkittel aber ohnehin
sei es geht nun mal winter lebe mit
gestorben sind oder wenn man sich für
schwangerschaft und entscheidet über
lächerlich maler franz behinderte oder
mich hin mobil geburt oder nach der
geburt sterben wenn man den text ruft
wenn man seitlich möchten abbruch so ein
fall ist sie twitter werkstoffe aber wie
vielen fällen ist es so zum seit ich
möchte ein abbruch wer wie haben wir
einen trainer wenn man doch vielleicht
selber eigentlich immer schlecht und
denkt ich selber habe entschieden dass
das internet wird leber weg führt ihn
immer der bibel nach entsteht weil wir
sind wenn zeige die kind stirbt wo in
chinesisch den überlege mir war nie
falsch gemacht wieso hanika sorgen was
ist passiert also ich immer dabei also
eigentlich gar nie darum dass junge
leute ziehen sondern geht und dass ich
so mies zwei die gruselige das fach
personen begleitet wo kontinuierlich ist
das mit ältere vertrauensbasis geht und
dem miteinander eine bewegung und trug
zum beispiel ansprechen der lage die
wache mit einem schuldgefühl machen und
der welt hört nicht auf wenn der abbruch
gemacht ist sondern er sei eigentlich
für viele altrich uns ganz schnell den
prozess sind inzwischen teil und dänisch
alt wie vorne beim vch hotel uns bewusst
sei was die chance jetzt plötzlich zeige
dich hin also für viele eltern
vorbereitet sind und kai begleitungen
ist es ein großes erstaunen weil sie
haben wir entschieden das finde ich so
wie ich bin objektiv und wenn es denn
geboren war die ich im winter heitz
geboren und du als vater gesessen
dann wird dies sind und das party das
ist zum beispiel bis sie war unglaublich
schlimm ich gesehen
oh ja die ganzen kaya die ganze liebe
kaufen wieder die stark sind also weg
damit ein buch tänze und kommissar boni
sind aber hat die hormone gepackt und
eben eine eher brust sparen hat
eigentlich schuss karten und mal wird
die frau wenn sie es noch weit bringen
und das ist dass ich unglaublich
irgendwie vom schlimm dass ich weiß mein
leben ist außer andere so dass im bett
lag und wüsste da ich christkind und es
hat mich verlegen haben und das kann man
ad knopf drücken und sagen du bist jetzt
hautnah als laut nature jetzt muss ich
halt zwei mal ist es gar nie
kontrollieren und das ist das ist extrem
wichtig war das ist für frauen müssen
wenn es für roma erleben dass das dann
auf suchen und sie denn extrem die
unterstützung bei vorgeburtlichen
untersuchungen wenn das dach besteht aus
findet trisomie hat entscheidet sich
dafür einen abbruch
und in der schweiz regelmässig vor und
hier sind die ersten monitor überhaupt
über so bis auf rädern ist der
chronische seines großvaters sz
chevrolet cruze respekt dass er da sieht
sie ganz dass er zeit und ihre
geschichte ist ein lied das ich absolut
nichts alltäglich absolute tappen und
intext größte tabu schwarzmeer alytus
haftet also das ist schon schlimm dass
das überhaupt gibt und dass menschen
sterben aber das wie sie noch vor
gesteht dass er diene die die nächste
generation das kind stellt ich habe mit
diesem weltbild passen friedrich und
beharrte zahlen geschaut wie so mehr
gesellschaftlich bedingt um fragen wie
was mach ich mir mit der vorgeburtlichen
untersuchung ist vater sie und natürlich
ein riesen griff fürs kind und der heißt
nicht dass ich möchte aber ich glaube
ich ist ganz wichtig dass wir uns als
gesellschaft wirklich gedanken macht was
für bedürftige die vorgeburtliche
untersuchung und was für konsequenzen
also ich gehöre ihr beirat für das 2 2
wieder die frage machen wir wieder bei
natale diagnostik oder nein
ich glaube schon dass für mit einzig
bergwerk zum zelten schwangerschaft in
taktisch so lange es förmlich spüren
also zum unterschied mache wenn ich doch
so hat es michael team hat dem
handelskonzern metro sieht chance zum
vierten kind stark war leichter beweise
die krankheit und überbrachte schon fast
vor allem über die basis habe das ich
setze respektieren weil ich was nun
dafür leben sie ihr leben zum teil auch
arabisch das ältere gesagt nachdem das
so einfach gemacht in die lehre zu sagen
und wie möglich hinter sich geprägt oder
missoni bezirken wie möglich sind mit 17
mit dem kinder unterwegs und ihre
schwangerschaft und dann sowas passieren
was passiert und melodik mit gebot was
großes spannungsfeld mit ihr auf der
eine sieht will maurer hätten wir also
die information natürlich oder aber man
will natürlich nicht das negative
informationen oder also recht eigentlich
bestätigung habe sich das mit dem regen
gar nicht richtig umgehen zumindest ich
nicht also sich irgendwie schwierig oder
denn denn das sind alles gute für ihr
lernen
die familie ist familie janousek und
familie janousek schon bourque ka und
hat als zwillingspaar die zwei meister
überholte michael kern gesund und andere
unheilbar krank
sarah und ihre eineiige
zwillingsschwester ja ein herz und eine
seele
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jannis ist der große bruder im bund
jahre kann sich nicht bewegen weder
sprechen noch selber essen
sie bekam vor der geburt zu wenig
sauerstoff im hirn wurde dabei fast
vollständig zerstört dass yara so schwer
behindert ist zeigte keine
vorgeburtliche untersuchung an
aber ich habe immer nur ein funke
hoffnung dass es nicht so schlimm ist es
blieb bei der hoffnung
die eltern nahmen das mädchen nach der
geburt heim zum sterben jahre trank
überraschend an der brust
wollt ihr leben
im inneren bald ist wieder mal gestorben
wo sie wirklich so traut sich was ich
immer gemacht hat ist sie wieder hoch
und groß aber auch kantig und ganz die
alte heute wird abgeklärt ob jara einer
medikamenten pumpe erhalten soll
die direkt in den bauch implantiert wird
das ist der punkt wo sie gewohnt die
pumpe soll schmerzmittel direkt in den
rückenmarkskanal abgeben
abgestimmt auf jahres bedürfnisse hätten
auch gemerkt dass mit der spastik
problem oft hilft die schmerzen sind
nach ins geschäft mit dem wenn es
irgendwie kritisch wäre das mache nur
über lange zeit lebenserhaltende
maßnahmen achten dass wenn man ihre
nicht zur mutter
diese chance will aber wenn ihre körper
das ist jetzt besiegt ist unethisch und
dann kommen sie auch vorziehen
ich musste albrecht zum zum inneren das
ist das ist mir gut aber sich aber nicht
sagen mich 1000 tests macht also machten
einfach weiter
[Musik]
und einmal mehr hilft die lebensfreude
der gesunden schwester der krise zu
trotzen
heute wird yara operiert endlich können
die ärzte die medikamente pumpe
implantieren
kann ich mich melden
seit jahren heute nach große schatz
jaroslav monik bereichsleiter teilt sich
immer noch in der operation
schwierigkeit geschafft wenn ich mir
nicola millimetern und ihre reaktionen
ihre bitte kümmert dass man das nicht
aber und da bin ich schon insofern weil
wir authentisch sind und einfach nie
weiß wer wie geht's weiter und
irgendwann wenn man maßnahmen finden
sehr geht's mir ein radikaler wechsel
machen turner vertreter familien
schlussendlich entweder ganz mit dem
irgendwie auch wieder live alles
belastet ist ich meine ich die robust
und dann zeit und so und da und aber
dann ist dusche und ein honey smacks
zeit und das heißt dass er ein
schlechter magisch oder das bezieht
schlecht ist sondern ich muss einfach
mal gesagt
selbst und gott ungefähr danke 54 mal
wieder aus dass gott im halbstunden also
schwierig alles wunschgemäß verlaufen
wie sie ja auch die auch baulich ist es
so nicht auszuspielen
danach haben sie operieren erhöht dass
ich wieder gesund dann ja aber so die
hoffnung jetzt wird es besser
es wird besser mindestens vorübergehend
familie janousek verreist in die
skiferien jetzt muss paul opfer
8 uhr an im aufmacher bis heute sind
aber im kreis problem jetzt so gibt's
noch media das wetter könnte schöner
nicht sein
schlitteln mit jana ja bloß
palliativmedizin am laf ist qualität
unterbreiten sagt springt er eigentlich
auf ein solches also genau wie machen
jetzt also mehr findet es wichtig und
das ist im moment wirklich aber qualität
[Musik]
[Applaus]
familie entstand eine callya 67 jahre
erhöht momentan gott sehr sehr gut
ja also sehr unterschiedlich der mertz
sich zum beispiel ganz ganz schlechte
monique sie wo sie verstorben wäre als
ganze schwere lungenentzündung vier tage
im spital und über zwei wochen und die
beautyklinik sie sind ganz ins spital
oder nehmen sie jetzt drei und sind bis
zum betragen also die die diskussion hat
er all die ganz schwierige entscheidung
lebensverlängernde maßnahme oder
november immer noch immer gut die
mögliche aber die ich glaube die blieb
wirklich bis sie stirbt ja also da muss
ich leider nicht vormachen die beliebte
steht aber jetzt einzig wirklich so gut
wie schon ganz ganz lange also sie lacht
sie ist es ist voll dabei die hand im
letzten dezember
der travel chef peter long
doch genau das ist eine von der großen
neuerungen aber extrem berichtet und es
hilft mit ihrer schwerbehinderung
was macht einen guten job macht
eigentlich ganz viel eher reduziert der
fall
er verhinderte fall r zeigt zurzeit zu
stoff sättigung saab-fahrer erteilen
wir haben das thema ihre neueste jahre
oder wie viel zeit darauf abzielt oder
probiert dort ist ab 20 4 brett idee
marokko bestimmt die stelle schlacke vor
allem im gesicht
während der fall und dann werden hormone
ausgeschüttet das sieht russe filmt oder
dass sie mit weniger medikamenten zu
finden mit dem man immer jeden morgen
und bevor werden sie am schlafen ist gut
checker wie sie schmeckt und wie ihre
dosis und dann je nach dem handelt oder
wann er den weg gespannt
das ist so eine für die großen euro gab
auch wieder viele sachen gemacht hat der
dank der trevis aber so fragen im chat
jahre als leben sie sagen das wäre ja
ganz klar
wenn sie gut gott wenn sie kleidungen
entzündet hat wenn sie keine schmerzen
hat vor der krankheit von rücken- oder
hüft oder was auch immer
es tönt zwar ganz extrem wie es ist
wirklich schwer spielt ist aber da muss
ich sagen sie lebt gern zur
schlüsselübergabe
so steht jeder körper schon längstens
man sie aber liegt mit einer
lungenentzündung im märz oder weil sie
dann will sie antibiotikum hatte
schlimmen durchfall hat dann muss ich
ganz klar sagen was soll das
und dann muss ich sagen nein dann muss
ich sagen nein nein und mehr handtuch
lied offene quasi nur dass dann wir
das ist ein risiko aber es ist natürlich
extrem schnell
also ich extrem schnelle oder warum will
sie auch so komisch wie sie auch nötig
ist will ich mir nicht vorstellen dass
sie so schön einfach komisch hofreiter
obwohl es mit jeder faser vom körper
bühnenshow obwohl ich kein gestank könig
spazieren und mein gedanke schlaf doch
jetzt einfach und ich merke erst einmal
wieder richtig holen und dann kann die
wii nicht mehr machen denn ist wie
kreativ sie liebt nämlich spazieren
fahren als ich einfach weg wenn sie mir
da so sehen weiß ich ganz viel zurück
denkt atmet sie der mutter ihrem
eigentlichen wünscht dass er sterben
das ist doch gott das ist casino die
humba der punkt wo sie sind punkt mir
und so wenig erwartet und sie also so
viel länger klappt als ich in die alle
danke hans das baby findet sie muss gar
nicht mehr
und wieso ist ganz schön schritt weiter
ich kann die frage nicht wirklich extrem
schwierig ganz viel schlimmste das man
wir und wünsche dass diese zeit von
schönheit so ist das nennt man jetzt wo
ganz viele verschiedene familien gehört
wie sie mit der pränataldiagnostik
umgehend die 1 die diagnose klar
die hat sich entschieden zum
schwangerschaft abbrechen
ich bin froh an ist nicht gewiss eines
netten entscheiden sie jetzt eine
gewisse sie ein zwilling im büro sein
tags und das andere jahre
schwerstbehindert wehrt sich vogts ist
während sich fokussiert
die pränataldiagnostik calvo wo sie
hinter grünen entscheiden soll passieren
immer darum oder war seit maradona nach
sind also wie kann ich das verantworten
dass ich ihre eigene zwillingsschwester
sagt wie sie so schwer behindert ist hat
sie krach durchs lappe und dusche aber
wann dies passiert und wie viel nach
hinten bis laufen sollte dann kann ich
dir einfach töten oder wie rechtfertigt
studios portier selten ohne dass ich
versetzt wird ich kann nicht entscheiden
wir unsere elite der situation
entscheiden
ich bin nicht getrieben dass jeder so
entscheiden wie es für sie oder fußball
stimmt also ein mensch wo alle
möglichkeiten hat ich akzeptiert und in
manschnow forscht drei möglichkeiten hat
akzeptiert dass conny wie forschende
rechtfertigen darum bin ich wirklich
froh dass man gesehen hat dass die alle
zwei wochen untersucht und
schlussendlich alles work sie bis zum
schluss und ja also eine schwere
behinderung wie das jahre hat das
betrifft das betrifft die ganze familie
was macht das mit der familie und macht
mit tradition es schwankt ganz extrem
oder was mit mir macht im moment bin ich
so oft kommt muss bruch kommt gott aber
das ganze chaos momentaufnahme
also weg vor dem vorteile blöde
opferrolle wann immer man die oberhand
die arm und ihre arme und das hat man
bei sony ist der mitte jara und mitte
jahr sagt was er für ihre beziehung zu
ihrer zwillingsschwester jan ist
gigantisch also ich behaupte jetzt mal
mit jahres in die geschichte
die wichtigste wie das ist normal das
ist lustig sie stritten sie lacht aber
wenn dir zwei ich glaube ich wirklich
skripte und das fehlt sie am lustigsten
oder
wenigstens lustig vielseitigen keine
sprach mit ihrer zwillingsschwester und
das glaube ich ihnen auch meine
schwester ist behindert muss ich muss
ich trotzdem aus oder sie können damit
umgehen
juli für war sind sie dankbar für die
probleme sind wo man kann kleintraktor
und für show auch für die liebe die ich
so dass das so kritik und optisch aber
die libido reingehen
das ist schon andere promis das ist
einfach anders wenn man so das bedürfnis
hat und wann ich finde ich würde mich
bezieht für darf dann gute chancen die
yara und dann kann die wahl und die
könnten aber praktisch möglich beim
beispiel jahren fertig und minimal
lustige wies hat das auch das sind die
schöne söhne situation hat das schöne
gefühl dass es für einen moment so viel
wird klebemittel jahre und für familie
alles gute mehr filme als die
koreanische der firma uns vor der nikolo
janousek dem rechtsformwechsel janosch
erinnert sich sicher ich liegen die
buchungen für das ende kennen gelernt
mit seiner älteren religiöser typ ist
ganz einfach wird die koreanische volk
seite die sagen einfach danke das ist
für uns wie eine andere welt durchgang
gewählt und ford kennt eben auch dank
menschen wohl nur banken ja nur kleine
geernteten
der familientreff in binningen einmal im
monat gibt es hier ein stelldichein für
familien mit kindern mit down syndrom
der moment als das kind auf die welt kam
ist für alle noch in lebhafter
erinnerung
nein
es war total überrascht weil wir bereits
abgesagt jeder geht mit gibt kann so
meins war sich wieder habe nicht gewusst
was heißt das am anfang war es sehr
schwierig die kürzesten akzeptieren aber
nach zwei drei jahre später
ich bin drei geworden gleiche sorgen
gleiche freuden und gleiche erfahrungen
und dann kann man uns keine gedanken was
sie war so oder so einer schwangerschaft
gefordert weil ihr kleiner test gemacht
und hatten in der zeit der
schwangerschaft so kann ich schon was
wenn das kind behindert ist
über diese frage mussten sie hier alle
gedanken machen
ihre antwort scheinen sie gefunden zu
haben
unsere nächste sendung reporter spezial
der germanist mittleres alter denn wenn
kinder schon größer sind und
einbeziehung wieder mehr isst zentrum
rückt wenn man sich fragen möchte ich
mit einem buch sich renault wird
business bis dahin
[Musik]